yes my name is Florence sighs I
represent the India Council from a
political economist one of the things
that we've been looking at in our
council has been the idea of inclusive
growth how to measure it how to possibly
rank the states in India the provinces
in India that have a potential benefit
to offer other states in India as a role
model so what's the discuss it has been
around that specific issue and we were
hoping to come up with some idea or our
models of inclusive growth as far as the
things that I think are interesting that
from looking at other councils is the
the linkages between India and Latin
America which are quite clear in terms
of the emphasis from corruption and also
was against social inclusion